y es momento de pasar a la revista de
prensa de esta mañana y vamos a comenzar
con el tema que recoge hoy toda la
prensa impresa alrededor del mundo el
encuentro de ayer entre los presidentes
de Estados Unidos y China Joe biden Abre
las cabeceras de los cinco continentes
pero vamos a hacer un repaso rápido por
las portadas de todos los países
implicados verdad Un saludo para ustedes
y Comencemos con global Times Buenos
días Ángela vamos a empezar con este
periódico de tendencia muy asociada del
partido comunista chino y titula en su
portada impresa el global Times se
reúnan mientras el mundo busca más
certezas ambos mandatarios se reunieron
por primera vez ayer desde que bailen
asumió la presidencia el 20 de enero de
2021 en una reunión de más de tres horas
donde Taiwán pues estuvo en el centro de
las conversaciones y supuso una de las
líneas rojas para el gobierno chino dijo
que la relación actual entre las dos
principales economías del mundo no tiene
buenas imp no tienes ni para los pueblos
ni para la comunidad internacional
Einstein a mejorar esas relaciones ambos
mandatarios coincidieron según esta
portada y este artículo del global Times
que fue un encuentro Franco profundo y
constructivo bueno que dice
Times
titulan conversaciones sinceras sobre
asuntos clave volvemos al tema de Taiwán
a trataron asuntos bilaterales pero esta
cuestión estuvo en el centro de las
conversaciones y además es importante
después de la visita de la presidenta de
la cámara de representantes Nancy pelosi
a la isla en el mes de agosto también en
Wall Street journal de se pronunciaba ya
del otro lado Sí en el lado
estadounidense el westing journal titula
este miércoles martes Perdón byden ishie
se esfuerzan por estabilizar las
relaciones Taiwán continúa siendo una
línea roja para Beijing y los
funcionarios de ambos lados se mostraron
favorables a continuar las
conversaciones
se puede materializar con una visita de
el secretario de estado estadounidense
Anthony blinken a China en principios de
2023 y el final
titula las tensiones por Taiwán
ensombrecen el impulso de byden She por
mejorar su relaciones y tiene uno más
para el cierre de este tema de Times
Este es un periódico británico en este
caso destacamos una caricatura de Peter
Book Book brooker Perdón que destaque El
encuentro entre ambos líderes Y si le
pregunta a byden si va a correr por la
carrera presidencial en 2024 y vaiden
agarrado por uno de sus funcionarios
dice que mejor va a andar recordemos que
va a ir en cumple en cinco días 80 años
y todavía estamos esperando si hay
confirmación de candidatura vamos a
cambiar de tema aportas desde el inicio
del mundial de fútbol en Qatar el
Washington post publica un nuevo
artículo de análisis sobre el debate
político en torno a la realización de
este torneo de Fútbol Internacional en
este país del Golfo Pérsico si Ángela
vamos a hablar un poco de las
implicaciones que tiene este debate
político acerca del mundial que arranca
ya este fin de semana dice este análisis
del Washington post que la indignación
en occidente ya era palpable en 2010
cuando se asignó la candidatura a Qatar
para que fuera sede de este mundial que
va a empezar ahora no esto ya se recogía
en la prensa occidental Entonces cuando
titulaban como catástrofe esto ha
seguido pasando y esto es un tema
recurrente 12 años después cuando el
sentimiento acerca de las implicaciones
que puede tener la celebración del
mundial el sobre todo en occidente pues
son controvertidas por ejemplo la
cantante dua lipa se ha negado según
este análisis del Washington post actuar
en la ceremonia de inauguración y dijo
que solo visitará Qatar cuando este país
cumpla con los Derechos Humanos además
aficionados del fútbol también se han
mostrado reacios a la celebración del
evento deportivo más importante del
deporte Rey en ese país del Golfo
Pérsico y en las últimas semanas veíamos
aficionados en Alemania con pancartas
que decían 5000 5000 muertos por
5.760 minutos de fútbol vergüenza
debería dar no En referencia a los
muertos que se estima que puede haber
ocasionado la construcción de las
infraestructuras en Qatar además
sostiene este análisis del Washington
post que incluso quieres apoyaron la
candidatura de Qatar como sede del
mundial ahora dicen que fue un error
aunque no hay pruebas de que la
candidatura pues haya estado manchada
por corrupción
sobrevuela todo este fantasma acerca de
la candidatura el país ha invertido
según destaca este análisis 220.000
millones de dólares para construir todo
tipo de infraestructuras que acojan este
evento deportivo sobre todo atrae la
situación de los trabajadores Porque el
85% de los tres millones de trabajadores
son inmigrantes la mayoría vienen de
países de África y del sur y el sureste
asiático las condiciones de
vulnerabilidad pues reportan que
pagan mal las condiciones de
habitabilidad de los trabajadores son
precarias y todo esto lo destaca este
análisis y todavía no se puede hablar de
corrupción a ciencia cierta bueno y
vamos a cerrar con otro de los grandes
titulares de la jornada hoy alcanzamos o
la cifra de 8.000 millones de personas
en la tierra National geografica hace un
repaso de las implicaciones que tiene
llegar a esta cifra veamos por favor sí
el National Geographic titula la tierra
Ahora tiene 8.000 millones de personas y
sumando A dónde vamos desde aquí se
pregunta este artículo hemos sumado mil
millones de personas en menos de 12 años
y las implicaciones para el planeta y
nuestro propio bienestar depende de cómo
abordemos el cambio climático no que es
un poco lo que veníamos reportando
también en el informativo desde la
aparición del homo sapiens hasta que
llegamos a mil millones de personas
reporta este artículo del National
geographical del National Geographic se
tarda 1300.000 años y fue en 1804 cuando
se descubrió la morfina Haití se
independizó de Francia o Beethoven
interpretaba por primera vez su tercera
Sinfonía en Viena este dato curioso en
National Geographic ahora los desafíos
que enfrentamos a medida que pasa el
tiempo y aumenta la población son
significativos por temas de
contaminación pesca excesiva y una
desaparición cada vez más acelerada de
la vida Silvestre los riesgos y
oportunidades cito textualmente de
nuestro auge demográfico y la crisis
paralela de recursos dependen en gran
medida de las decisiones que aún no
hemos tomado el mundo combina además
grandes explosiones demográficas y
colapsos al mismo tiempo por ejemplo
como destacábamos también en el
informativo china dejará en 2023 de ser
el país más poblado del mundo y por
ejemplo en África la tendencia es
totalmente la contraria Nigeria por
ejemplo la Edad Media es de 17 años y
esta combinación de poblaciones en auge
y declive dice este artículo del
National Geographic aumentará la presión
migratoria en casi todas las partes del
mundo y la justicia climática gracias a
usted Marta precisamente vamos a hablar
de eso más adelante con nuestro invitado
del